maybe you can unpack with me what's
going on okay so here's where I've begun
in just the same way as I did before I'm
like oh cool I've got a pair of
equations this pair of equations is even
nicer than the previous one because both
of them are y equals and y equals so you
just put them together you can just
connect them directly okay which is like
oh that's handy and then you start doing
what you normally do right what can I do
to simplify this equation I'm gonna add
X to both sides right because it's a
minus X minus X so if I add X to both
sides
what will I end up with on the Left plus
to write that plus doesn't go anywhere
and then on the right hand side I get
zero now you look at this you're
thinking okay so now I should factorize
a guess and then you run into a brick
wall right so so you could I mean we
could we tried it over here and you're
like oh what else can I do right so you
could subtract two from both sides but
then this leads to even more problems
right because now we're saying hold on
there's some number and you square it
and apparently you get negative 2 all
right now when you take the square to
both sides you're like okay this is not
happening right what do you say of this
you have a way to conclude this right
you would say no real solutions right
okay there are no answers to this now
I'm gonna ask you the same question here
you know how we got to the end we got to
the end of here we got some values for X
and be like cool are we done and you
told me no right well here I've found
there are no values for X are we done
the answer is no I have not answered the
question the question says find the
points of intersection if there are no
real solution what does that mean about
the points of intersection
it means well
yeah des mots there right key pulled it
open and you've got a different pair of
equations to put in this right yes it
doesn't work that's it
yes sir look yeah it doesn't it's not
happy with you either is it so let's
have a look at this okay so here are my
old equations so let's get some new ones
in here what do we say x squared
what was my equation minus X minus 2
minus X plus 2 thank you
okay are you seeing what I'm seeing
right so here's my parabola right here's
my straight line and what's it doing
it's like yeah yeah yeah see you later
okay bye right where do they intersect
answer
they never intersect the reason why we
found no real solutions is because there
are no points of intersection there's no
guarantee that you get intersection
points sometimes that's exactly what
you're supposed to find that they never
intersect that was kind of the point
so my conclusion my actual thing that I
would write at the end of here is there
are no points of intersection that's my
answer right you asked me to find them
but they don't exist
okay so just because you didn't get any
numbers at the end that doesn't mean you
can't answer the question the answer to
the question is there are no points of
intersection okay well I've written my
fancy are here at this point to indicate
like what could I do with that equation
answer that's as far as I could go but
now I'm going to there it is now I'm
going to come back to the original
question just like I did in this line
here right it's like you asked for
points I'll give you points right say it
again well I don't I don't have any
points like look at this line of working
it there are no points so my final line
will be there are no points of
intersection
or I could say they don't intersect
either would be the same okay for a
second we're all getting to some various
points and raising some really great
questions so that's why I want us to
reconvene so just have a look at my
working and I want to ask you this
question it's not finished yet but I
just want to ask you whether this is
what you wrote down or something
different do you think that what I've
written so far is okay like have I made
any mistakes or does it check out to you
because I do make mistakes have I made
any well we could both be wrong I don't
know do we have consensus I'm not I know
I'm not finished but does this look okay
to you
okay good now some of you go to this
point and you're like oh whoa what do I
do with that like I know that
factorizing was a thing I should try to
do but that looks gross like what do I
do with this thing right now some of you
for example you're like oh these guys
have a common ex I'll take an ex out
right then you go to X times 2 minus X
and then like this guys are just hanging
around you what a jerk right now this is
part of why early on when we first learn
about quadratic equations right we said
hey we like to write our quadratic
equations in this form right and just
like with the straight line here right
we call this what form general form
right now general form is not the only
one we also learnt about vertex form we
learned about this form you remember
this guy you can write a minus or a plus
there right so this is to help you find
the vertex we looked at this we did I
promise okay so general forms not useful
for everything but it is useful for
factorizing and at the moment part of
why this looks gross is because it is
not in a nice neat general form okay so
here's what I'm gonna do
firstly as I have written up here right
I'm gonna write it in the correct well I
helped a more helpful order alright so
I'm gonna write it with the x squared
term first and then the X term and then
the constant like so okay these are
equal but I can make this even better
for myself see how that is that minus
sign there don't like minus signs minus
signs confuse my brain so can someone
tell me something I can do to both sides
that would get rid of that - so yeah
okay so you can add x squared to both
sides I guess if you were going to do
that you would have to subtract 2x as
well and you'd have to add one as well
and everything ends up moving there's an
easier thing I can do which just leaves
everything where it is but without a -
oh yeah if I multiplied everything
through by negative one this first term
would turn into X square what about the
next one - 2 X and then the next one do
you recognize this is something you can
factorize you should write what kind of
it's not just any factorization what is
this it's a special factorization it's a
perfect square thinking it's so I can
write this as something all squared what
is this something
X minus 1 now here we've seen this
before right how many solutions are
there to this particular equation
there's just the one right and this will
give us a y value of y equals one
takeaway 4 which is negative 3 so I'm
getting this and that's the only point
that I'm getting now some of you would
like really I mean we got two solutions
one time we got 0 so this is the next
time could we get just one solution well
let's have a look what were the
equations I gave you x squared minus 4
and what was the other one
- x - y - 5 - x - y minus 5 okay what do
we got here what does this mean
it intersects at just one point and in
fact it just touches is exactly the
right word this is actually worth
writing down can I ask you to where
you've done the working for this
question can you draw for me a rough
sketch of this it doesn't have to be big
or beautiful doesn't have to be precise
but there's actually something important
I want to catch here this blue line here
on this particular graph it gains a
special name and again it's a name we're
gonna make a big deal out later but it's
an annual I actually already know when a
line just kind of goes by and just sort
of touches it starts with the T does
anyone know this from this is called a
tangent now tangent this is how you
spell the word tangent T am G E and T
there's another word in the English
language that comes from the same place
as tangent when something when you can
touch something like this table right
you can touch it so we have a word for
that we call it a tangible object it's
tangible because you can hold on to it
as opposed to like a number is that you
can't hold a number right now the fact
that it's just touching that just
intersects just like that makes this
line once you've drawn that straight
line on there can you please label it as
such this is a tangent it's pretty
special we'll come back to it a bit
later on okay all right now this last
one I'm actually not going to get you to
do the last one right now I just want
you to look at it I'm even gonna be nice
and show you the working for it so just
put your pens out of your hands for a
brief moment the reason why I included
this one in the list is that sometimes
you get two solutions sometimes you get
none sometimes you get one but all the
questions you've looked at so far the
answers have been like really nice and
neat haven't they what do we just say um
one negative three that's this solution
right but if you have a look at that
last one there I think I've got it just
you this is what happens you start to
put them together and then you get to
this thing and you're like ah gross I
can't think of a way to factorize this
so you do what you should normally do
which is go towards the formula or
completing the square and you're going
to get some numbers out of this
eventually you get some numbers but
because they're not nice you get thirds
flying around
mainly you can't do this question it
just means that when you do it
your answers are going to be a little
bit gross looking okay if you go ahead
and you put this into desmos what you'll
find is it would just hand you some
weird decimal values when you look for
where those points of intersection are
okay but these are the actual spots
where they exist so it's just a caution
that often your solutions will be nice
and neat but there's no guarantee that
they have to be because you can totally
solve them even when they're not it just
takes a little more patience and a
little more care all right